[Music]
the winners and champions of Dancing
with the Stars athletes are
other than Jenna
[Applause]
honestly exhausted our stars intercept
or the Stars and I swear ended yesterday
and so we came here and I said you know
what I'm gonna put it all out there and
I did and honestly I talked about this
talked about that like are you guys
gonna stay in touch this is this is a
special connection here we have our name
on this forever you can't get rid of
make the record show Adam rippin and
Jenna Johnson's names are forever
engraved well printed is this gonna go
next to the bronze medal next to the
totally I mean I this has been such an
incredible experience
you know just pushing yourself out of
your comfort zone and and more than that
getting to meet somebody who I'm gonna
be friends with for the rest of my life
it's just been such an incredible
experience and I saw Val backstage yeah
is your sport yes my cheeks hurt so I'm
so happy I'm so happy he's here and my
family flew out and I'm just I'm
overwhelming
what do you say to you he just kissed me
a lot that's a good what was his
reaction to your telling her calling him
out for asking her to get married seems
like you guys have got into this really
great and I mean pretty serious please
for my times a-tickin
well after we did that he retweeted and
said I should put a ring on it so
you